Speaker 1: with an update on the
Russian invasion of Ukraine. Because,
yeah, there's been less media coverage of
this, but that doesn't mean there aren't
newsworthy things happening. And it is going
so poorly, according to new reports for Russia,
that there are renewed questions as to whether
Putin is, quote, doomed, which we will get to in
a moment, Reuters and others. But we'll look at
a Reuters report reporting that Russian troops
are fleeing and getting back over the border
into Russia. Russia has largely ceded its gains
near Kharkiv, writes Reuters. And many of the
withdrawing Russian soldiers have exited Ukraine,
moving over the border back into Russia.
This is per a senior U.S. military official.
As it pulls back, the U.S. has seen anecdotal
reports of Russian forces abandoning equipment.
Again, disorganized command and
control, as mentioned. That's been
that that's been a hallmark, a
staple of Russian activity so far.
The remarks to Pentagon reporters followed a
weekend of rapid gains for Ukrainian forces.
Ukraine's general staff said its soldiers had
recaptured more than 20 towns and villages in just
the last day as Ukrainian forces swept deeper into
territory seized from fleeing Russian troops. Now,
the big stories here were, of course, a war of
aggression by Russia. That's an accurate and
true story. Expectations early that this would be
a very easy military win for Russia. Very quickly,
that assumption evaporated. However, there
was the belief that although on the one hand,
the longer it went, the worse it is for Russia,
that eventually, if Russia decided to commit
the resources, it would overwhelm Ukrainian
troops. That's not happening. And in fact,
things are going in the opposite direction. The
U.S. military official reads the same article, was
upbeat but cautious when describing the Russian
advances. It's clear they're fighting hard.
Ukraine said it repelled attempted Russian
advances in two important areas of the Donetsk
region, the city of Barmouth and Maersk,
near the coal producing town of Horlivka.
The general staff said in an evening update. But
the senior U.S. official said Russia was still
focusing its firepower on Bermuda. So a lot more
tactical information that you can read, if that is
interesting to you. Now the question becomes what
about the propaganda war and what about the future
of Vladimir Putin? There's an interesting article
in The Hill which is worth reading. If not,
it's worth reading, let's just put it that
way. And it's it's by Alexander Motul,
who's an opinion contributor, and it says,
like his soldiers, is Putin doomed? Now,
the article is somewhat hyperbolic, admittedly,
and the article writes, Vladimir Putin is kaput.
The proof of that is the below letter written
by a 26 year old soldier in the Russian army,
Vivi Tarasenko. We know nothing about Tarasenko,
except he was a resident of Putin's brainchild,
the so-called Luhansk People's Republic, and that
he has a wife, Valeria, and a small son. We also
know Tarasenko died in battle during the recent
Ukrainian offensive in the Kharkiv province.
Ukrainian intel found the letter. The letter was
written with little punctuation and no capital
letters. So the letter reads. This letter is for
the future if I should die or be taken prisoner
or become a vegetable. Written July 17th, 2022.
It's very hard to write. I'm crying, but I must,
beloved. Lera, tell our son what kind of dad I
was, that we were sent as cannon fodder to Zalman,
a village in Kharkiv province, without armor,
without ammunition, without normal weapons.
This is about our situation. When our son
grows up, tell him his dad wanted very much
to return home to be the best dad ever. I've been
drinking and I'm writing emotionally. I know that
this all will be forgotten and that you will
be living your own life. That you'll find a
new husband. That I'll simply disappear in
the war like all the guys. Unfortunately,
I didn't have a normal life. Say that Dad
was an athlete, didn't smoke, didn't drink.
It's terrible that everyone has forgotten me. It's
very hard to accept all this. But all people die
and this cycle can't be changed. It's bad to die
in the summer. If only I were at the seashore. And
what is written in this Hill article is that
Tarasenko complaints are not unique. The Russian
leadership with Putin at the head has evinced a
profoundly cavalier attitude towards lives not
just of innocent Ukrainians, but also of Russian
soldiers. And what this article and others go on
to say is that there is really no path out of this
for Putin. That is going to be anything short of a
of a failure and doom for Putin. Now, earlier,
there were all of these speculations as Putin's
sick and has a death wish and is determined to be
assassinated eventually by operatives from other
countries. Or is Putin so drunk on the idea of
reassembling some version of the USSR that he's
not thinking clearly? And whatever the case may
be, I at this point think the ship has sort of
sailed on making rational sense out of what Putin
was thinking and when he was thinking it and what
the end goal is here. But it is clear that if
there is going to be a win for Russia. It's
going to be a win only with completely revised
objectives. And so at this point. When this didn't
end in two weeks, we started talking about, well,
it's likely going to be more than months at this
point. And what is the ultimate goal? Because a
complete and total takeover of takeover of Ukraine
seems increasingly unlikely. It seems quite
plausible that Putin and his cronies will revise
their military objectives and they will revise
them to say, our goal is actually to control a
lot less territory than we initially planned. With
those revised objectives, they may be able to come
away with something that they would call a win
for propaganda purposes. But there's also a fear.
The fear is that as Russia and Putin realize,
we're not going to be able to continue mounting
offensives and really take Ukraine in the way that
originally some projected us to do. There's the
fear that an increasingly belligerent Putin will
resort to those tactical nuclear weapons. These
are sometimes called battlefield nuclear weapons.
It's not like the massive bomb that destroys
entire cities, but they are battlefields or
tactical nukes. And that that would be something
that Putin is willing to do to kind of maintain
this image of strength, the kind of harebrained
caricature of the alpha male that has pervaded the
MAGA movement in the United States. Quite frankly,
it's sort of a similar dynamic that is a fear
that an increasingly cornered Putin would go
in that direction. So it is unpredictable
what is going to happen. But what we know
is that it is not going well for Russian
troops and there is still an invasion,
there is still a war, even if more and more a
mainstream corporate media isn't talking about it.